everyone welcome back to how to
Hollywood I'm your host Kristen Gill and
today I'm going to be doing this Lady
Gaga inspired Grammys tutorial two years
ago David Bowie passed and the Grammys
were the next month
Gaga did a beautiful tribute to him on
stage and also just looked amazing on
the red carpet wearing that orange hair
and these just glitzy eyes and Sarah tan
oh did her makeup and if you guys want
to learn how to recreate this look then
please keep watching
[Music]
okay so I already have all of my face
done except for this eye so I have my
blush on I have my foundation I've tried
to cover my eyebrows as much as possible
I don't want to cover my eyebrows
totally because Gaga has hers bleached
just like bleached out so I put some
concealer in there and just brushed it
through with a little spoolie and now
starting out I'm going to be using a NYX
jumbo eye pencil just pretty much all of
this is going to be drugstore makeup and
it is in the color Pacific and I'm just
going to map out on my lid which is
already it's got a little bit of
concealer on it I'm just going to be
mapping out where I want and how high I
want this eyeshadow to go I'm just
putting it on my lid too because I'm
going to go on with eyeshadow I'm just
gonna slap that on after obviously your
eyes are different on both sides so you
want to make sure that you're trying to
make them as even as possible
Sarah tahno used all Sephora collection
so I'm just trying to base mine off of
hers but with drugstore I wrote an
interview with Sarah recently where she
said like she and Gaga have been really
trying to do looks that like anybody can
do and I really think that this is
possible obviously it takes a little bit
of time because of the rhinestones but
it's super simple now that I'm done
mapping out the eye I'm just going to go
in with some eye shadow that's a shade
darker this is a NYX eye shadow and it's
the color blue jeans and I'm just going
to pack it on my lid and bring it all
the way up and this part can be really
messy
okay so I'm just bringing it up onto my
brow bone to and I'm just bringing it
down just a little bit so I'm using a
Mac 209 brush for that this is just a
flat shader brush and I use the tip just
to go right in the corner right here to
not bring it any higher I really want to
keep this kind of precise I mean there's
no rhyme or reason in this area but you
definitely want to have it a little bit
more precise right here and I keep my
mouth open most of the time while I'm
doing this so I'm just going to start
with my darker eyeliner right here this
is also a NYX product I am not sponsored
by NYX by any means and also real quick
I forgot to say these gems are not
Swarovski I'm sure Gaga's probably were
because she's Gaga but mine are just
from any craft store I just have a light
blue and a dark blue back to eyeliner
okay I am going to start out by getting
this top waterline darkening it up and
then just kind of bring this eyeliner
and following it along the line we did
before which is darkening up just the
outer edges and this eyeliners really
soft so it's really easy to manipulate
I'm just going to face forward make sure
they somewhat match because this is
gonna be covered by all the gems you
don't have to worry about it looking
super perfect
[Music]
and then just using a pencil brush I'm
going to go right over top and just
smudge it in and I know this look meant
a lot to Gaga because she was such a
huge Bowie fan
she was crying actually when she was
getting her makeup down just tears
streaming down her face like it gets me
teary-eyed just thinking about it but
she was such a huge Boy fan that she
even got a tattoo of him like he had
passed a month before in January before
the Grammys 2016 and so this was just
such a moment it was really impactful
I'm going to bring that NYX eyeliner
down on my bottom waterline I brought it
in a little too far hers is a little
more silver and white underneath but I
got a little crazy on this side I want
them to match so I'm just gonna go with
it I'm just going to copy the other side
by bringing this down as you can see
it's super smudgy so it's really easy to
work with but you can also get carried
away going in with my pencil brush again
I'm just going to smudge that along the
lash line bring it up using another
jumbo pencil this is in the color
cottage cheese I'm just going to bring
this on the inner corner and down to
that blue and bring it a little bit
underneath the blue little subtle and
then I'm going to bring it on top of the
blue eyeshadow we did before taking a
covergirl palette I'm using a white
shade right here it's just like a pearl
shade and I'm just going to push that on
right where I had just done the jumbo
pencil
so it connects with that blue so much
blue that cobalt blue Marc Jacobs dress
was insane it was so gorgeous and the
orange hair just really giving her
everything to Bowie such a moment I'm
just going to use my concealer brush and
just clean up underneath and check
forward I'm sure we're on point looks
like it okay so now I'm starting with my
rhinestones this is the funnest part and
I'm using some lash glue you can use any
kind of lash glue and I'm just going to
alternate like I did on this side with
the light blues and the Dark Blues I
just used into three of those I think
like six or seven on the top and then
the rest you can just kind of go to town
I start by looking down at the mirror
and then I put the gem like right where
my irises
and for the first 30 seconds your glue
is still pretty tacky so you can move
things around pretty easily
[Music]
definitely a look that you can wear out
to like the grocery store or you know
the drugstore whatever you're doing
rhinestones are done I'm just going to
use a little bit of mascara to finish
off the look and this is Tarte maneater
mascara it is my ride-or-die I always
tell everybody about this mascara it
doesn't make your lashes look spidery at
all
this is the final look inspired by Sara
tano and Lady gaga
for the 2016 Grammy Awards she did a
beautiful tribute to David Bowie a
Grammy Awards are going to be in New
York City this year and it will be on
CBS this Sunday January 28th from 7:30
to 11:00 p.m. and I can't wait to see
what Gaga's going to be doing this year
thank you guys so much for watching and
please like and subscribe to
entertainment tonight's YouTube channel
follow me over on Instagram I'm at
Kristin Gill XO for the next six months
till I get married and I will see you in
the next one bye guys
[Music]